Rockets have been raining down on Harkey
for months
and the apartment buildings in the
eastern district of sultivka have borne
the brunt of it
Leonid lives on the first floor
the impacts have ripped through his
apartment
destroying Walls Furniture the
refrigerator
with his window panes gone the wind
blows right through the flat
Leonid is trying to prepare for the
winter
I'll figure something out and look
around to make things Pleasant and
comfortable for myself I might buy a
sheet of metal attach it here and make a
hole in it I could set up a wood stove
because you can cook on that and it
gives off heat
that would help Leonid be less dependent
on electricity
when a Russian rocket hit this power
plant near harkive his flat was also
affected by the blackout
parts of the power grid in eastern
Ukraine were out for hours there was no
electricity or running water and the
subway in the city with more than a
million residents Stood Still
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians were
sitting in the dark without power
homes hospitals schools Municipal
infrastructure Russian Rockets are
aiming straight for targets that have
nothing to do with our Armed Forces
infrastructure
in president zielinski's hometown of
criveerich a dam was severely damaged
several streets flooded and the drinking
water supply to the city of more than
six hundred thousand largely stopped
working
Russian attacks on critical
infrastructure in Ukraine are on the
rise
the government fears the country is
facing its toughest winter since gaining
independence in 1991.
that's partly why so much maintenance
work is currently underway like here on
a substation in the solomonsky district
of Kiev the team from the local power
grid is preparing the capital to weather
the cold season
they are very aware of potential attacks
on the grid
but these attacks keep up there may be
interruptions to the power supply for
residents and other consumers
but we're preparing for that kind of
scenario
we've put together plans in coordination
with the municipal Administration and
the Central Energy System
if that happens somewhere we'll do our
job
[Music]
the war has caused the country's energy
consumption to plummet much of the
industrial sector has shut down and
millions of people have fled abroad
energy experts say Ukraine is currently
using 40 percent less than its average
electricity and gas consumption they say
the country is prepared for winter
we have enough gas reserves and enough
coal we might even make a profit from
selling power
we can make it fine for the winter
but only if Rockets don't hit our
infrastructure such as our combined heat
and power stations nuclear plants or
other power plants if they get hit
they'll stop working
that's part of the reason why the
government is urging people to also
independently prepare for winter
Lucia is running out of time her house
near hostel airport was hit half a year
ago by a Russian projectile
the only reason she and her family
survived is because they'd already fled
yeah
at first I cried a lot it was really
hard for me
my 14 year old son got up in the morning
and said mom don't cry I'll rebuild your
house
they're currently staying at their
neighbors but in just two weeks they
will have to return to their still
unfinished house which they've been
rebuilding with the help of volunteers
there is still no Heating
I need a boiler
so solid fuel or electric but they both
cost money and that's really unrealistic
for people who've lost everything
Lucia is thinking about taking out a
loan to protect her family from the cold
the war has stripped ukrainians of
security
many households are tight on money
and millions of people are heading into
the winter months plagued with
uncertainty